hey guys this is Vadim with max tech and
this is the iPhone 11 Pro max in
midnight green and in this video we're
gonna compare it to the iPhone 10s max
and see what changed whoa Wow look at
that oh man so this looks really really
nice so as you guys know it has the
matte finish right on the back and wow
it feels like really smooth
let me grab the iPhone 10s max here and
like this is like glossy like like it
sticks to your finger this your finger
just literally slides off and as you
guys know the camera bump as well it's
not matte it's glossy there's no iPhone
text on the new one and wow this
midnight green color I've got to say
that like only at certain angles you can
tell that it's green it's like very very
slight it's not like a real green that's
more like a Space Gray but with a little
little tint so one thing I could tell
right away is the camera bump on the
iPhone Tenace max is larger it seems
like the iPhone 11 pro max house like a
two-step thing with the square and then
each little camera each lens has its own
bump which is really awesome I really
like how it looks and looking at the
sides it seems like all the buttons got
pushed down slightly as you guys can see
right here the power button went down
just a little bit and so did the SIM
card tray right here and on the other
side the volume buttons and everything
else just went slightly lower that means
your cases might not fit perfectly but
this is actually pretty nice because
it's easier to hit the buttons now that
they're a little bit lower so I don't
know if you guys can see that in the
top-down view but you can see how much
reflections is on the 10s max and on the
front there's literally nothing that
changed like it's identical on the front
with a notch and everything and the new
pro max is definitely heavier I could
feel the difference right here in my
hands and here's another difference
there's actually a difference in the
clicking sound when you press the button
I don't know if you guys can hear this
but uh well don't want to do that all
right so we're getting this guy booted
up we're gonna restore it from iCloud
backup by the way guys if you're getting
the new iPhone 11 or their new iPhone 11
Pro or the pro max we're actually gonna
have a video tutorial on how to backup
all your data with either iTunes
or iCloud and then also how to reset
your old phone so you can sell it or
trade it in alright so I got the food
set up and before we move into comparing
these two bullets I want to mention the
18 watt fast charger that now comes in
the box finally we're moving away from
that crappy 5 watt charger and getting a
real fast charger in the box which is
amazing
alright so the first thing I want to
test out is faise ID speed I got both
phones right here and I'm just seeing
how fast that little lock turns on
actually one thing I'm noticing is that
I'm pressing both buttons at the same
time and more often than not the iPhone
11 Pro max is turning the display on a
lot quicker than on the tennis max it's
actually very interesting so Apple did
say that you get better angles for face
ID so let's test it out right now okay
both of them didn't catch it how about
now both of them got it just go back a
little bit oh that time the 11pro got it
Apple did say it works from further away
so let's test out the tennis max so I'm
holding out my hand as far as I can and
it's not even detecting up there you go
down locked but there it's not detecting
my face at all let's test out the 11pro
same thing it's not detecting my face
honestly I think that was a bunch of
marketing because I'm not noticing a
difference in distance or angles the new
iPhones do have the new a 13 Bionic chip
compared to the 812 and iPhone 10s max
but you're not really going to notice
that like at least while browsing
swiping through they both feel very very
snappy the difference is going to be in
the camera and actually the battery life
the iPhone 11 pro max is rated for five
hours more than the iPhone tennis max
and they did that by making a much
larger battery I think it's almost like
eight or nine hundred milli amp hours
larger than the tennis max which is
really really impressive so now let's
actually test the performance using the
classic Geekbench four so let's open up
Geekbench four we're actually gonna do
Geekbench five as well so cpu benchmark
that's right so the test finish and as
you guys can see there actually is a
decent difference coming from the a 12
to the eight 13 coming from around 4,800
to a fifty four hundred and thirteen
thousand multi-core this is really
really impressive
honestly this completely blows away any
like Android smartphone the tennis max
was already as powerful in raw
performance or more powerful than the
other Android phones this just takes it
to another level it's really awesome and
with that I'm gonna go and run the
compute graphics benchmark and Wow check
out this difference in graphics this is
actually really impressive I was not
expecting this much of an improvement
seeing as the graphics is actually more
efficient this year so with that let's
jump into Geekbench 5 and see how these
scores go so we got the scores back on
Geekbench 5 and we're actually seeing an
awesome difference around 50% more
multi-core performance which I was not
expecting this at all
seeing as Apple is focusing more on
efficiency than performance we're
getting so much more performance at
least in this raw performance test the
display on the iPhone 11 pro is
basically identical to the one on the
tennis max it's just brighter and has
better contrast now looking at it like
this I can't really tell any difference
in contrast but what I am gonna do is
I'm gonna max out the brightness on both
Follett's and see if there's any
difference
I just maxed out the brightness and Wow
I can instantly tell the difference no
joke the iPhone 11 Pro max is a lot
brighter than the tennis max so I'm
watching a youtube video and I could
instantly tell how much more bright the
iPhone 11 Pro max is it looks really
really good I'm actually surprised how
much brighter it is than the tennis max
now let's go ahead and test out the
speakers to see if they're louder on the
11 Pro max let's start off with the
tennis max
[Music]
so what I'm noticing so far on the
iPhone 11 pro max is that you hear more
difference between all the little tones
like there's more dynamic range I guess
you can say like whereas this feels a
lot more flat the tennis max does okay
there you go that is the big difference
so the iPhone tennis max has all of the
highs or a lot of the highs coming from
the top speaker but on the iPhone 11 pro
max it's actually very balanced with the
highs from the top and the bottom all
right so let's finish off with the
cameras as you guys can see here we do
get a new UI slightly different on the
iPhone 11 Pro max we used to have this
little circle where you can switch
between the telephoto and the wide but
here we actually have three settings now
we have the ultra wide the wide and the
telephoto now the selfie camera got a
huge upgrade from 7 megapixels on the
tennis max to 12 on the iPhone 11 Pro so
let's go ahead and test out the quality
so I'm gonna put both of these photos on
the screen for you guys and just let me
know down in the comments if you can
tell a difference I also took a portrait
selfie and I'm noticing a massive
difference so one thing that people
complain about on portrait selfies in
the past was that your shirt gets
blurred out as well as a background but
it looks like Apple reversed that and
now your shirt my shirt is fully InFocus
it's fully detailed so this definitely
looks a lot nicer in my opinion now
let's test out the rear-facing portrait
mode I got this plant right here let's
see what can do a better job at portrait
blur edging it's kind of hard to tell
which one looks better on the screen so
you guys let me know down below but the
cool thing about the iPhone 11 Pro is
that you can shoot portrait photos with
the wide lens as well which you can't do
on the iPhone 10s max even with iOS 13
and just for a measure I'm going to add
in a few more examples of portrait
photos so you guys can look at both of
them and see if there are any
differences and how much better the
iPhone 11 pro max is and finally there's
the new night mode now I've been playing
around with it for a little bit now but
notice that it does not work in the Asha
wide lens it only works in the white and
the telephoto lenses and it turns on
automatically so I'm gonna post up a few
photo examples of night mode versus the
Tenace Max's regular photo without flash
and you guys could let me
know what differences you see as you
guys just saw night mode makes a massive
difference when it's dark and actually
turned off night mode on the iPhone 11
Pro Max and I noticed that even with
night mode off it's actually a little
bit more sharp with less noise compared
to the tennis max I also tested out the
ultra wide lens and it seems like the
white balance is so much better on the
iPhone 11 Pro max compared to the 10s
max which was really really cool
in this shot specifically so I think
Apple is using the wide lens for all of
the white balance and it's transferring
it over to the ultra wide lens and the
telephoto lens so it stays very
consistent and finally let's finish off
with some video recording now Apple did
mention that if you're shooting at 4k 60
you now get extended dynamic range
whereas on the iPhone 10 s max it only
works up to 4k 30 so you guys can look
at both of these clips and see if
there's any difference in dynamic range
or quality or anything else
alright so there you guys have it those
are comparison between the iPhone Tenace
Max and the iPhone 11 pro max now we're
going to be doing a lot more comparison
tests and videos and other stuff like
that so make sure if you're not already
subscribed you click that circle above
subscribe right now and check out some
of those other videos right there
thanks for watching and let us know what
you thought about this comparison down
in the comment section below
[Music]